Hi.
I'm Murat Ogat.
I'm the co-founder and
manager of Kuka Apps, which
is a mobile
application development
company in Istanbul, Turkey.
I would like to talk about
how we use the Google Maps
and Directions API and Location
Manager in the Android platform
to create an app which tracks
the user movements to mobilize
the users and create
awareness about breast cancer.
By creating an app
that constantly tracks
the routes of the
users, the main idea
is to constantly get the
locations of the users,
and compare it, and calculate
the distance between them.
So the main problem
we had at the start
was to get locations of
the users constantly.
There were two methods
for getting the location.
One from Wi-Fi and
the other from GPS.
And we had to experiment
with both of them.
The Wi-Fi location
can be obtained
almost instantaneously, but
it can be very inaccurate,
up to 50 meters sometimes.
And this was
unacceptable for us,
because it added
up really quickly,
and displayed to the user the
wrong estimation or the walking
distance.
The GPS location takes
some time to warm up.
But after a couple
of seconds it can
give very accurate locations,
up to one meter or two meters.
That's what we
needed, so we opted
for using the GPS location.
Although the points from
GPS could be very accurate,
even with two meters
of inaccuracy,
they could be placed on a
building instead of a road.
And users were generally
walking on a road.
If you take the road
points here from the GPS
and display it on
a map, this would
draw a route that
would go constantly
inside buildings, and
outside of buildings,
and sometimes even over the sea.
So we used the Google Directions
API to solve this problem.
Basically, what we did
was to get the point
and not use it as raw data.
But send it to the
Google Directions API,
and ask for a route,
starting from that point,
to a point that we
had measured before.
What the Google
Directions API returned
was a route from these points.
And the first
point of this route
was actually guaranteed
to be on the road.
We also had to implement our
own Location Manager that
filters the data and determines
whether they are usable or not,
before passing it
to the app engine.
You can see here that the
function's main purpose
is to determine whether
the newly received
location is better than the
previously received one.
First, if the accuracy
of the received location
is less than 30 meters, you
just attribute it to a bad GPS
signal, and ignore it.
Otherwise we compare it to
the previous measurements.
If the measurement
is not less accurate,
or is obtained more
recently, we set it
as the new location of the user.
All apps that start services in
the background, and especially
use GPS data, must be very
aware of their battery usage.
If this is not done
well, it can quickly
drain the battery of
the device of the user.
The app only records the data
points [? of the ?] device
in the background, and we try to
defer every calculation, or web
service queries, that
would consume battery
until the app has been put
to the foreground again.
The total distance
covered by all the users
would be set as the
basis for the donation.
And we didn't want our client
to pay an extra amount of money
for distance the users
actually didn't walk.
And we, of course, had some
server side and client side
checks for that.
And what we did on
the Android platform
was based on speed and
location of the user.
And the speed we could get
from two different sources.
One is based on location points.
We got the average speed.
And also the Location
Manager can give you
an instantaneous speed, with
all the locations it delivers.
So we checked the
speed values, and if it
was above a certain threshold
we stopped the walking
immediately.
This prevented the user from
recording bicycle rides,
or car rides, or it
filtered out the users who
started walking and then
forgot about the app
and entered the vehicle.
And that sums up how we solved
some technical problems, why
we produced a walking, tracking
app that users GPS data.
Thank you.